l'heure est à la hausse du thermomètre
et hausse des prix tout augmente avec la
tva les transports les voitures les
péages et bien sûr les cigarettes
l'assassinât de la petite karine et
l'arrestation de son meurtrier un
récidiviste jacques toubon ce soir
envisage de modifier la loi pour
aménager un suivi médical de ces
délinquants sexuels après la prison dans
le journal également la réunion du
congrès à versailles et la modification
de la constitution la plus importante du
pont depuis celle de 62 qui avait abouti
à l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel
et puis la bosnie où la situation se
détériore chaque jour un peu plus les
combats ont redoublé d'intensité toute
la journée entre serbes et croates
autour de la poche de biache et puis
enfin le dernier film de bruce willis
inspecteurs madeleine y reprend du
service une troisième fois ça s'appelle
une journée en enfer et on ne s'ennuie
pas une seule seconde
bonsoir on appelle ça les hausses de
l'été mais les hausses étaient cette
année on ne sont exceptionnels
puisqu'elles sont provoqués par la tva
qui passe de 18 6 à 26 % à partir de
demain la cigarette sera presque à un
frange parle d'une seule cigarette les
sens les voitures les transports les
alcools tout grimpe
sandra smith et eric george o se sont
donc rendus à nice pour voir comment les
commerçants à les répercuter cette
hausse de la tva sur les touristes et
bonne surprise
ils sont plutôt modérée du cocktail sur
la plage au confortable matelas pour
bronzer les doigts de pied en éventail
tous ces services sont soumis à la tva
de 26%
mais à nice les plagistes n'ont pas
l'intention de répercuter la hausse
en pleine saison 5 actuellement
les audois de choses à faire mais je
trouve que c'est aberrant de nous
raconter c'est eva un 1er août le 1er
septembre est très bien je crois que le
gouvernement commet une faute vis-à-vis
de nous n'est pas une faute grave pour
eux vu de paris et pour le tourisme 5
d'azur c'est grave
mauvais coup également pour les
accessoires de l'été le bateau
pneumatique ou la serviette de plage
font partie des produits manufacturés
certains commerçants ont fait valser les
étiquettes le temps des chaussures en
plastique à 49 ans est révolu elles
coûteront désormais 50 francs malgré
tout les hausses restent limités on peut
pas augmenter dessous les prix trop trop
d'articles d'un magasin c'est pas
possible tu en fais passer à la
clientèle des tp qui n'a déjà pas
beaucoup d'argent qui n'achètent pas
facilement c'est pas possible
et puis il ya les plaisirs de la table
et la dégustation des spécialités
niçoises
si vous l'emportez vous mangez de la
soca à 5,5 pour cent sur place avec le
service l'addition est plus salée
toujours le même condiments l'activia et
restaurateurs eux aussi sont amants on
attend la fin des vacances à l'année
prochaine parce que les gens dès que
c'est cher ça au monde qui viennent pas
chez nous mais si vous allez à la poste
prendre un bus sont obligés de passer
par la cie comprendre l'essence ils sont
obligés de passer par là nous il peut me
sens ils peuvent s'en passer de manger
de la soca moins de touristes des
consommateurs prudents les
professionnels de la côte d'azur
assumeront la hausse de la tva pour
l'instant leurs prix risque d'être plus
chaud l'été prochain les appels se
multiplient à la brigade criminelle
après la diffusion hier de trois
portraits robots par le ministère de
l'intérieur trois hommes présentés comme
des témoins importants dans l'attentât
de mardi dernier à la station
saint-michel les mesures de sécurité se
sont encore renforcées à lyon notamment
où la préfecture de police annonce
qu'elle a procédé à plus de 11000
contrôles d'identité depuis l'attentât
l'enquète elle va sans doute pouvoir
progresser les experts sont en effet
parvenus à identifier l'explosif utilisé
il s'agit de nitrate de méthyle enquêtes
et révélations de michel fille voilà
déjà près d'une semaine que les experts
du laboratoire central travail sur les
débris retrouvés dans la rame et il
devrait rendre bientôt leur rapport aux
magistrats selon nos informations les
ce terreau du labo aurait découvert des
traces de don crac de méthyle un
explosif puissant liquides et volatils
de couleur légèrement jaunâtre le
nitrate de méthyle comporte des
caractéristiques identiques à celles de
la nitroglycérine
mais c'est un explosif moins instable
donc moins dangereux à transporter en
1986 le réseau bdg parfois de salah et
qui avait organisé la vague d'attentats
utilisé un explosif similaire
aujourd'hui il n'est pas facile de se
procurer du nitrate de méthyle voilà
pourquoi certains enquêteurs envisagent
l'hypothèse d'un attentat organisé par
un réseau plutôt structurés un commando
par exemple venu peut-être de l'étranger
et qui aura bénéficié d'un soutien
logistique en france
mais ce ne sont que des hypothèses de
travail depuis la diffusion des trois
portraits robots hier soir à 20 heures
les services de police travaille
d'arrache-pied en milieu d'après midi
l'état major de la police judiciaire à
paris avait déjà reçu plus de 180 appel
en province
quelques personnes ont été placées en
garde à vue pour vérifications
pour l'instant les renseignements reçus
non pas vraiment permis de faire avancer
l'enquêté mais tous sont méthodiquement
velux et 20 personnes sur les 86 blessés
au cours de l'attentât sont toujours
hospitalisés françoise rudetzki la
président de l'association sos attentats
étaient reçus ce matin par le président
jacques chirac
elle a salué la décision du chef de
l'état de mettre en place auprès du samu
une cellule de prise en charge
psychologique des victimes d'attentats
et elle souhaite qu'un hommage soit
rendu aux sept morts de l'explosion et
puis en italie à trieste un
ressortissant d'origine marocaine a été
arrêté avec un faux passeport français
alors qu'il était en possession d'une
sorte de manuel pouvant servir à
préparer des explosifs on le sait depuis
hier soir l'homme qui a tué violé la
petite karine de 11 ans retrouvée
étranglée à redon était un récidiviste
il était sorti de prison il y a trois
ans après avoir été condamné à dix ans
pour viol sur mineur il s'était ensuite
installé à redon avec sa femme et ses
trois enfants
cette affaire relance bien sûr les
interrogations et les inquiétudes
comment traiter ce genre de délinquants
sexuels
anne ponsinet après sa condamnation à
dix ans de prison
en 87 pour viol sur mineur de moins de
15 ans michel bazar est ce qui n'a passé
effectivement que six ans en détention
il n'a bénéficié en cela d'aucun régime
de faveur c'est le système normal des
réductions de peine pour les détenus qui
se conduisent bien en prison
un système mal compris par certaines
associations qui réclament une plus
grande fermeté pour les délinquants
sexuels
si l'assassin de karine était restée dix
comme titulaire l'avait demandé
karine serai encore là ça d'une part
d'autre part le soin pendant
l'incarcération et le suivi obligatoire
une fois qu'ils sont libérés après sa
sortie de prison michel bazar et ce qui
n'a pas suivi de psychothérapie
difficile également de suivre une
pendant la détention car dans ce domaine
la france est particulièrement en retard
jusque là jusqu'à 1993 la loi française
et l'organisation française ne prévoyait
strictement rien il n'y a pas de
recherche en france dans le domaine des
troubles des conduites sexuelles
gravissime est important et il n'y a pas
de dispositif social qui permettent
d'assurer un suivi
si michel bazar et ce qui avait été
canadien peut-être aurait-il purger sa
peine de prison pour viol dans cet
institut de montréal ici pédophiles
violeurs ou exhibitionniste sont
sérieusement prise en charge par des
médecins et après leur sortie ils
peuvent encore être suivie et voir un
psychologue en cas d' alerte en france
des dispositions comparables sont à
l'étude depuis plusieurs années je
réfléchis aujourd'hui à améliorer la loi
pour pouvoir imposer je suivis après la
détention qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
dans la loi alors que la loi en ce qui
concerne la peine elle même est déjà
extrêmement sévères quant à la prise en
charge thérapeutique des délinquants
sexuels pendant leur détention
elle est actuellement impossible il n'y
a pas assez de psychiatres en prison
avec nous dans ce journal docteur
cordier bernard cordier bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes médecin psychiatre vous êtes
aussi expert il vous est aussi membre de
la commission qui a en charge d'étudier
les façons de suivre ces
et détenu en prison vous partager la vie
de jacques toubon voudriez aussi
modifier la loi pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse quand puis suivront ces
délinquants après la prison oui il faut
il faut absolument qu'on se mobilise et
que l'élan qui a été insufflé depuis 93
ne retombe pas et qu'on puisse proposer
effectivement des soins valable car à
quoi ce à quoi ça rime de parler d'
obligation de soin s'il n'y a pas tout
ce qu'il faut comme formation comme
information et comme résultat à la clé
alors vous êtes vous êtes si tu as des
experts quand vous trouvez face à ce
genre de personnage qu'est ce que vous
cherchez à déterminer la mission de
l'expert tout d'abord pendant
l'instruction c'est de rechercher si le
sujet est un malade mental au sens le
plus pathologique du terme
en l'occurrence les sujets qui
commettent de tels actes ont d'une
anomalie dans un secteur donné
celui de la sexualité est généralement
ils fonctionnent assez bien dans
d'autres domaines
ils ne se font pas remarquer c'est
souvent monsieur tout le monde et donc
le rôle de l'expert est d'abord de
rechercher l'éventuelle existence de
maladie et angie considéré à priori
comme des râpes à priori mais enfin vous
les considérez c'est le cas comme des
malades
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un expert
psychiatre est en mesure de dire face à
une personne qui éventuellement été
condamné pour ce genre d'agression si
elle est capable ou non de récidiver si
jeanne on laisse sortir de prison
assas et l'expertisé à la sortie à la
sortie alors l expertise de la sortie
elle est toute nouvelle elle a été
instaurée par la loi baigne riz et donc
elle prévoit que l'on se penche sur le
comportement du sujet tout au long de sa
détention sont sa participation à des
soins et pas seulement sa bonne conduite
au centre pénitentiaire des centrales
sont des gens qui se conduisent plutôt
bien en plus généralement il ne faut pas
parler d'eux sauf qu'ils subissent
souvent une mise en quarantaine de la
part des autres détenus on appelle on
les appelle les pointeurs ils sont ils
font l'objet de brimades parfois pire
mais
il y à il ya vraiment une mission
nécessaire pour arriver à les soigner
et alors et enfin de détention à ce que
aujourd'hui que les connaissances de la
médecine actuelle psychiatrie ce que
vous êtes capable de dire si quelqu'un
est en mesure ou pas de récidiver le
nous n'avons pas à pouvoir de prédiction
on peut se baser sur différents facteurs
que l'on cherche à faire varier les uns
les autres pour m
évaluez évalué l'avenir ce que nous
recommandons c'est que le suivi soit
l'ont bien contrôlé et plus long même
que ne le permet la loi actuellement
nous pensons que le vol a changé
l'obligation de soin doit être de longue
durée alors je vous interromps une
seconde nous allons revenir bien sûr à
cette affaire mais en angleterre au pays
de galles les photos de trois enfants
assassinés ce week-end font également la
une de la presse britannique il s'agit
de deux affaires distinctes mais dans
l'un des cas au moins l'enfant aurait
fait l'objet de sévices sexuels avant
d'être assassiné véronique taveau
une poupée de chiffon
un bouquet de fleurs et ses quelques
mots en souvenir d'un ange
depuis hier soir les témoignages de
sympathie affluent sur le lieu du crime
ici allant d'une no au nord du pays de
galles
sofia avait 7 ans son corps dénudé a été
retrouvé sur cette plage hier matin la
fillette a été violée puis étranglée
sophie était et sera toujours pour une
petite fille d'une vivacité
extraordinaire d'une intelligence rare
et d'une très grande beauté
je m'adresse à celui qui peut aider qui
peut connaître même le plus petit détail
je lui demande d'aider la police a
démasqué le monde qui a fait cela notre
sophie l'angleterre choqué l'angleterre
qui se mobilisent contre la bestialité
l'horreur les corps de paul barker 13
ans et de robert trouille hamdi 12 ans
ont été retrouvées près dé liverpool
samedi
on ne sait pas encore s'ils ont été
victimes de sévices sexuels
les deux enfants étaient partis à la
pêche ils ont tous deux été assassiné
et si pour l'instant la police juge peu
probable l'existence de lien entre
l'assassinât de la petite sophia et ce
double meurtre
la presse elle fait la une sur ces trois
visages
avec ce titre le massacre des innocents
mise en garde
en cette période de vacances
surveillance accrue appel à témoins des
centaines de policiers sont aujourd'hui
mobilisés pour tenter de trouver les
responsables de ce triple meurtre
d'enfants une règle stricte ici en
grande bretagne un condamné pour crime
sexuel se rencontrera l'intégralité de
sa peine et sera suivi psychiatriquement
en prison et s'il venait à obtenir une
remise de peine
c'est alors l'opinion publique qui se
mobiliseraient pour empêcher la
libération d'autocars dit on sait que à
l'étranger notamment au canada travaille
beaucoup sur d'autres pistes pour ces
délinquants las on appelle ça la
castration chimique alors vous
connaissez bien la question que je
travaille depuis une dizaine d'années là
dessus c'est une solution envisageable
castration chimique
il s'agit pas d'une castration il s'agit
d'un médicament dont les effets sont
réversibles donc le mot est pas tout à
fait adapté nous travaillons là dessus
nous avons des résultats il ne faut pas
non plus croire que c'est la panacée il
n'y a pas de pilule miracle dans ce
domaine de coupe-faim sexuelle efficace
il y à vous savez tout de la fonction
sexuelle une quantité de variables en
dehors même des taux hormonaux c'est une
fonction extrêmement complexe qui met en
cause l'éducation la culture ça ne
suffit pas mais c'est utile des
résultats c'est utile parce que il ya
des personnes qui vont récidiver avant
même les résultats des traitements les
plus classiques de type psychothérapique
une dernière chose la loi la loi
méhaignerie l'a prévu donc un
allongement très très important des
peines pour les délinquants de ce type
tout ça peut aller jusqu'à 30 en une
espèce de peine lorsqu'un meurtre
absolument le quatrième meurtre et viol
c'est cette place le chemin en fait
d'une espèce de mise à l'écart de la
société de ces individus là c'est une
solution pour vous aussi ou est-ce que
vous pensez que vous médecin vous pouvez
maintenir ces gens dans la société en
les contrôlant je pense que cette loi
était promulguée dans un contexte où
nous pouvions pas nous si quatre
médecins corps médical répondre aux
défis qu on nous lance maintenant
clairement d'où parvenir à des résultats
dans ce domaine
mais je voudrais souligner qu' on peut
pas le faire seul il faut qu'il y ait
une mobilisation pour la prévention
de tout le monde famille les enfants
parlent aujourd'hui les familles doivent
pouvoir évoquer ce problème avec leurs
enfants
il faut il faut faire peut-être je
dirais pas comme aux états unis parce
que notre culture est différente mais
sachez que quand un pédophile sort de
prison aux états unis il
il doit prévenir ses voisins qu'il est
pédophile et qu'il vaut mieux cartes et
leurs enfants
c'est impensable en france celui qui
sonnerait ce french est immédiatement
mais voilà des petites mesures peut-être
dont nous devons nous inspirer les
chansons lesquels vous travaillez voilà
actuellement merci eu beaucoup dr corby
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
toujours à propos d'enfants en belgique
la gendarmerie et la protection civile
ont entamé une âme une immense battu ce
matin dans la région de liège pour
tenter de trouver deux fillettes de 8
ans disparue depuis plus d'un mois
et puis à fontenay-sous-bois un drame
familial 7 me un homme a tué sa femme et
ses quatre enfants à coude de 22 long
rifle il a ensuite retourné l'armé
contre lui pour se donner la mort
personne n'a rien entendu
la carabine et est équipé d'un
silencieux selon les premiers éléments
de l'enquète une mésentente conjugale
serait le jeune homme à l'origine de ce
drame
l'actualité politique et l'adoption
comme prévu par le parlement réuni en
congrès de la réforme de la constitution
adoption par 6 174 voix contre 178 c'est
la réforme de la constitution la plus
importante depuis celle de 62 qui avait
amené à l'élection suffrage universel du
président de la république
c'est ce qu'a déclaré alain juppé le
premier ministre le président at il dit
doit pouvoir dialoguer avec l'ensemble
des français en dehors des échéances
prévues reportage à versailles de carole
que mon et bernard ont foulé pour
l'adoption 674 contre 162 vu le congrès
à l'issue du vote ne faisait aucun doute
d'où peut être la décontraction des
parlementaires à leur arrivée au château
de versailles en tout début d'après midi
mais malgré la fin de session et surtout
la chaleur il a bien fallu se rendre
dans l'hémicycle pour voter la plus
importante révision constitutionnelle
depuis 1962 une révision qui prévoit
notamment l'extension du champ du
référendum et l'instauration d'une
session unique du parlement
c'est le premier ministre alain juppé
qui a ouvert les débats avant que nous
se succèdent
la tribune les représentants de chaque
groupe parlementaire
cent dix minutes explications de vote
sans surprise la majorité se prononcera
pour et l'opposition contre le texte
il est extrêmement important non pas
pour lui-même et parce qu'il est le
préalable un certain nombre de réformes
qui sans lui ne pourront se faire des
réformes par référendum dans certains
domaines ce sera indispensable domaines
économique et social et des réformes du
travail de l'assemblée
si on ne veut pas continuer les dérives
auxquelles nous assistons depuis de
nombreuses années nous n'avons dans
cette réforme rien sur l'indépendance de
la justice
il n'y a rien sur les renforcements des
droits du parlement c'est-à-dire de la
démocratie il n'y a rien sur les
renforcements des droits de l'opposition
d'hier là aussi de la démocratie et par
conséquent ses traits fins et une
occasion manquée le début mai 110
minutes
même le dernier jour voilà qui peut
paraître bien long et pendant que
commence le vote
tout récemment informatiser le spectacle
surtout à l'extérieur au bureau de poste
d'abord où l'on s'arrache le timbre
spécialement unis pour le congrès à la
buvette aussi ou encore dans les jardins
à 19h la bonne nouvelle arrive enfin le
vote est terminé la révision
constitutionnelle adoptée
cette fois ça y est les parlementaires
sont enfin en vacances et la 76e mission
d'ariane est reporté deux jours les
électrovannes part et il fonctionne mal
le vol devrait avoir lieu dans la nuit
de jeudi à vendredi
si tout va bien à l'étranger les combats
se sont intensifiés au sud ouest de la
bosnie entre croates et serbes combats
au mortier et à l'artillerie près de la
poche de biatch après que le président
croie tu es rejeté l'accord en six
points proposés par les serbes de
krajina l'onu se dit ce soir pessimiste
sur les chances d'éviter un conflit à
grande échelle dans la région chaque
merlino les combats s'intensifiaient se
développe dans tout l'est de la bosnie
ainsi que dans la krajina
ici ce sont les soldats gouvernementaux
bosniaques par les forces serbes dans la
région de borny vac ouf ont
manifestement leur armement s'est
améliorée
là ce sont des soldats croix qui
fortifient leurs positions après la
conquête de grands mots et 2 gla match
ils ont réussi la prise d'une route
stratégique et menace maintenant la
ville de knin fief des serbes
sécessionniste de croatie ces
différentes attaques interviennent alors
que les serbes de bosnie et de croatie
continue de bombarder la poche du bi h
c'est donc toute la zone frontalière
entre la bosnie et la croatie qui
s'enflamme aujourd'hui la violence de
ces combats se traduit par des nouveaux
exode de populations plusieurs milliers
de serbes de bosnie fui devant l'avancée
des forces croates étant de trouver
refuge à knin il serait selon les
sources entre 5 et 20 min
dans le même temps la force de réaction
rapide continue de se déployer ce matin
à split un contingent allemand a
débarqué un hôpital de campagne au
complet et toujours à spip
une délégation iranienne a entamé un
voyage officiel ali akbar velayati
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
est en route pour sarajevo afin d'y
apporter le soutien de son pays et la
grande majorité des effectifs de la
vanne 4e brigade aéromobile britannique
destiné à rejoindre également la force
de réaction rapide devrait quitter la
grande bretagne d'ici la fin de la
semaine
les français eux vous le savez sont déjà
sur place avec la légion gilles rabin et
laurent hamida ont rencontré un tankiste
français en lisière de forêt près de
sarajevo
même quand elle est bien filmé la guerre
ne peut pas cacher sa brutalité eux ne
doutent pas qu'ils sont venus ici pour
se battre se battre contre les serbes
et il se prépare
camouflage
on peut essayer de faire de la place
pour pas être trompée l'avenir le chef
le sergent chef a fait descendre les
trois blindés de son peloton au plus
près des lignes de front les gens au
niveau de la gare safran a cédé par un
monopole
le chef des bons c'est un soldat de
métier
18en armée dont 15 dans la légion la
légion étrangère c'est son univers une
vie qu'il s'est choisie et qui n'aiment
maison peut-être pas un deuxième guerre
mondiale qui avait été fait prisonnier
ici la part les allemands étaient
déportés en yougoslavie sylla s'est
marié avec meego somme bojan cette
avenue ton en dessous
en 96
casques bleus n'ont pas de casque bleu
c'est une victoire est là pour que pour
l'humanitaire le chef ses poubelles et
c'est son vrai nom fauvel jacques chef
de char chef de peloton il a déjà fait
la guerre au tchad
fauvel jacques c'est un professionnel
un technicien de la gaine c'est son
métier c'est sa vocation non c'est bien
en acquisitions l'objectif chargement
beau but elle aimait trilla there il en
comptait selon me suis engagé j'étais
célibataire je suis marié ma femme a
bien voulu rester avec moi bon c'est que
c'est bon
en permanence ici avec moi périodes mais
en même temps du côté d'aaa brahms et
beethoven borodine berlioz bizet ballack
est une musique avec la musique sans
avoir pas une petite symphonie offrant 5
une symphonie aux canons de 105 mm et
vida résultats positifs grossesse voit
la façon de bonnes nouvelles
c'est ce parti un garçon parce que j'ai
deux filles pour l'instant mais on verra
enfin petit j'attends
rens
la police et l'armée israéliennes sont
intervenus pour évacuer des colons qui
s'était installé sur une colline de
cisjordanie
ils entendaient ainsi protester contre
le projet du gouvernement israélien de
restituer aux palestiniens certains
territoires
la police israélienne n'a pas hésité à
détruire les cabanes et a déchiré les
tentes les courants avaient installés
dans ce secteur
et puis en espagne le tribunal suprême a
commencé à examiner le dossier
d'instruction du juge garzon dossier sur
le gal groupes antiterroristes de
libération est un dossier qui porte des
accusations assez lourde contre le chef
du gouvernement espagnol felipe gonzalez
il va encore faire très beau demain très
beau très chaud et très sec
toutes les conditions sont donc réunies
au déclenchement des feux de forêt pour
y faire face les préfets ont la
possibilité de mettre en place un plan à
l'âme comment se déroule un plan alarme
exemple dans le var avec olivier théron
et céline hué
voilà ce qui arrive à la moindre alerte
14 groupes d'intervention ont été
déployés dans les zones les plus
sensibles du bar ces cinq camions
constitue la plus petite unité efficace
de lutte contre le feu objectif de ce
positionnement stratégique pierre
d'angle du plan alarme la rapidité notre
mot d'ordre c'est frapper vite et fort
pour ne pas que le feu prenne de
l'importance puisque ça va très vite
nous faut donc intervenir le plus
rapidement possible on le fait avec les
hélicoptères mémoire vidéo on le fait à
partir des casernes et lorsque le père
l'armée déclenché on le fait à partir
des points stratégiques sur le terrain
où on injecte des groupes d'attac prêt à
bondir aux ordres du codis 81 3 le codis
81 3 c'est le centre opérationnel
véritable point névralgique de la lutte
contre le feu c'est lui qui a déclenché
le plan alarme en fonction des données
météorologiques la lutte prend parfois
des allures de partie d'échecs grandeur
nature le positionnement des unités est
établi en fonction des risques et des
départs de feu là encore l'objectif
c'est la rapidité
depuis le 1er juillet il y a eu 30
incendies en forêt heureusement chaque
sinistre a été maîtrisé sans dommage
mais avec la canicule qui persistent et
le vent qui se lève
la partie d'échecs devient tous les
jours plus compliqué de nouveaux
bouchons se sont formés pour la
troisième journée consécutive ce matin
dans la vallée du rhône bouchon de 23 km
entre montélimar et valence sur
l'autoroute a7 et à partir de demain la
situation pourrait devenir difficile aux
approches de paris puisque l'autoroute
a6 sera fermée dès ce soir dans le sens
province-paris et que l'autoroute du
nord l'autoroute a1 sera coupé également
à hauteur de saint-denis tout cela bien
sûr en raison de travaux explications
david calvet et roger mature à minuit on
ne roulera plus pour cause de travaux de
réaménagement l'autoroute paris lille
sera fermée dès ce soir 3 km de travaux
qui rendent difficile la circulation
entre paris et la province
il s'agit de préparer la section
d'autoroute de saint denis qui a besoin
d'améliorer ses infrastructures
routières la ville doit abriter en effet
le grand stade période de l'année moins
denses en circulation le mois d'août est
celui des grands travaux et les
automobilistes le savent
ça c'est moi où il ya moins de personnes
sur paris donc c'est
c'est plus évident pour retravailler moi
je me souvenir il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
jacques diop au chant par ailleurs dans
la mesure du possible il est conseillé
d'éviter paris deux itinéraires bis
l'a104 et l'a86 sont recommandés
l'autoroute de l'est permet de rejoindre
la capitale des recommandations pas
toujours pratique pour les
automobilistes qui devront donc savoir
patienter dans les inévitables bouchons
alors parce que les bouchons je vous
propose maintenant de découvrir le plus
grand et le plus vieux musée à ciel
ouvert de notre pays la vallée des
merveilles la bien nommée dans les alpes
du sud selon la croyance de nos ancêtres
c'était le domaine des dieux reportage
alban nicosie et céline c'est la
montagne sacrée
la demeure des dieux dans le sud des
alpes à 2870 mètres d'altitude le mont
bégo des livres peu à peu tous ses
secrets
ici il y à quarante siècles les premiers
hommes nos ancêtres sont passés y ont
déposé sur la pierre en guise de message
si gravure étrange le secteur grave et
correspond à un carré de quatre
kilomètres de côtes et finalement ou
plus de 37000 gravure ont été recensés à
l'heure actuelle c'est à dire qu'il
pouvait y en avoir beaucoup plus à l'epo
37000 gravure au moins mais seulement 9
motifs différents poignard personnages
et surtout cornes en abondance
l'association de ces différents signes
laissent penser qu'il y a là les
premiers essais de langage dessiner un
peu comme les hiéroglyphes et puis
découvrir les rites de ces premiers
hommes nous aide à comprendre les
ressorts de certaines traditions comme
la corrida
aujourd'hui lorsque le taureau le torero
sur l'arène de nîmes d'arles au de
madrid aux de seville sacrifie le
taureau il reproduit le geste du prêtre
de l'âge du bronze qui représentait sur
cette dalle qui sacrifie le taureau pour
qu'il fait quand de la terre s'il
revenait sur terre aujourd'hui le dio
toro serait sans doute un peu surpris
sur les pierres des centaines de crétins
contemporain on a posé les marques de
leurs bêtises sans parler des gravures
régulièrement voler du coup le site est
fermé au public non accompagnés par des
guides à serment c'est dommage mais cela
permettra aux scientifiques de
travailler sereinement sur l'étude de
ces premiers
civilisation européenne comment bronzer
sans douleur et sans risque au bord de
l'eau la croix rouge française investit
les plages pour la deuxième année
consécutive
et elle explique à tous ceux qui veulent
l'entendre ce qu'il faut faire et ne pas
faire pour éviter de ternir ses vacances
marianne masse et marc du min 28 degrés
en bord de mer avant de force 2 à 4 pas
vraiment la canicule ici à fort mahon
mais quand même de quoi prendre de
bonnes couleurs savoir ce qui vous amène
ici
le coup de soleil c'est pour ça que je
peux bien un gros coup de soleil qui
aurait pu tourner au malaise parce que
les méfaits du soleil ne sont pas si
anodin qu'on le pense la croix rouge et
cette année sur les plages pour informer
et initier les vacanciers aux premiers
gestes de secours
j'ai appris comment les gens soient
conscients comme on est sauvé c'est le
coeur bon et utile en apprenant la
technique du bouche à bouche du massage
cardiaque des gestes simples mais aussi
des conseils élémentaires pour affronter
la canicule difficilement supportable en
particulier pour les personnes âgées et
la recommandation qui ai fait la
parousie comme partout c'est de boire
beaucoup de ne pas attendre d'avoir soif
au bois pour se protéger contre une
déshydratation qui viendraient avant
même qu'on la ressentent war beaucoup ne
pas s'exposer aux heures les plus
chaudes et plus tôt bouger que rester
immobile des conseils simples à
respecter surtout pour les enfants vous
mettant de la crème pour protéger
surtout sur les épaules le visage ou si
vraiment le soleil est très fort
nous laissons les t-shirts et bayod
enfin ça n'est pas parce que le vent
souffle fort que le soleil ne tape pas
et pour supporter la canicule le
meilleur remède c'est encore de rester
dans l'eau au carnet rose retenait que
la jolie sophie marceau comédienne de
profession a accouché d'un petit garçon
et il s'appelle vincent il va bien sa
maman aussi
stéphane haumant la scène s'est passé
ici à la maternité de l'hôpital antoine
béclère dans le rôle de la star cacher
sophie marceau dans le rôle du papa
célèbre pourchassé par les paparazzi le
réalisateur polonais andrzej zulawski et
dans le rôle du médecin
le médecin ce 6 mars a donné naissance à
un petit vincent de près de 3 kg 900 et
tout s'est bien passé comme on dit la
maman et le bébé se portent bien
lors du dernier festival de cannes
l'actrice affichait une maternité
épanouie pour se réaliser 10 et elles
faire un enfant c'est encore mieux que
de faire des films
bon ça se passe quoi on ne sait pas très
bien ce qui se passe mais ça se passe et
c'est tout le mystère de la vie alors
que c'est finalement le cinéma devient
mystérieux une fois c'est fait et
pendant sa fabrication
le petit vincent est né lundi dernier à
20h02 très précise celle qui fut
l'adolescente de la gomme commence à 29
ans une nouvelle carrière difficile
celle de maman d'un enfant de star alors
si les matous jour mais à l'écran
l'inspecteur maclaine et de retour
mclaine alias bruce willis à peine
dessaoulé de ses deux premiers films le
piège de cristal et 58 minutes pour
vivre de succès mondiaux et bien à
cannes arrive en force sur nos écrans ça
s'appelle une journée en enfer
nicolas vainqueur ça s'appelle une
journée en enfer
allez savoir pourquoi a évidemment cette
efficace vous venez de voir la plus
importante scène d'explosion jamais
tourner à new york une bombe une vraie
qui a soufflé à rez-de-chaussée et
réduits en miettes une petite dizaine de
voitures
accrochez vos ceintures pour la
troisième fois bruce willis reprend le
rôle du détective john mcclain je ne
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais ça
devrait bardet
dans quelques heures simon contactera le
lieutenant maclaine pour lui dire ce
qu'il doit faire et le lieutenant
maclaine s'exécutera qui est seemo pour
l'instant c'est un mystère on sait de
choses c'est un fou furieux et illange
presse allemand au détective john
mcclain qui n'arrête pas de se faire
plein d'horribles méchant bobo il y à de
l'action dans l'air
il y a deux maires dont hugo
peyremale est prêt accroche toi ça va
secouer
et
bobo la limousine touboul de 4,4 bobo le
budget 60 millions de dollars
le mystérieux saimone en l'occurrence
jérémy iron se voulait en fait deux
choses la vie de john mcclain et lors de
la réserve fédérale
le casse du siècle rien que ça
les scènes de cascades sont à peu près
tout dans ce goût là quant au dialogue
ils sont riches sont vives
ils sont rythmés
pour la traduction ça devrait aller je
pense explique bruce willis que la
valeur pas seulement parce qu'il est
distrayant mais aussi parce qu'il est
porteur d'un message
ce sont toujours les bons qu'ils gagnent
si vous aimez les inondations les trains
qui déraillent à l'heure des explosions
de paquebots les promenades en taxi
youpi youpi youpi mêmes cris peu youpi
youpi
john mcclain s'apprête à avoir un
horrible problème à partir de mercredi
ça s'appelle une journée en enfer
personne n'a oublié la fameuse dream
team l'équipe des basketteurs américains
qui a enflammé les jeux deux olympiques
de barcelone est bien la nouvelle dream
team celle d'atlanta est presque prête
magic johnson n'en fait pas partie il
aurait pourtant bien voulu quant à
michael jordan lui il a décliné l'offre
présentation yann lavoix 7 et il ya
trois ans à barcelone les stars du
basket américain n'avait pas raté leur
premier rendez vous avec les jeux
olympiques
beaucoup de joie et beaucoup d'or pour
une équipe en or larry bird michael
jordan patch winch barclays magic
johnson pour la première fois les
meilleurs joueurs d'europe ont vu de
près à quoi ressemblait des monstres
sacrés après barcelone
il eut bien une dream team ii mais sans
la magie de la première alors pour la
green team droit qui jouera aux jo
d'atlanta
on a appelé quatre anciens de barcelone
john stockton sera l'un d'entre eux karl
malone a été également rappelé tout
comme scottie pippen des bulls de
chicago le quatrième c'est david
robinson le pivot des san antonio spurs
élu meilleur joueur de la nba cette
saison aux côtés de ses anciens on
retrouvera en laye où un vainqueur des
deux derniers titres de champion aux
états unis ressuscitant il a pu être
sélectionné par les états unis malgré
son origine nigérien il côtoiera l'autre
star du basket américain d'aujourd'hui
shaquille o'neal et puis la dream team 3
à opter pour la jeunesse celle de glenn
robinson et servent de point tenir
ils n'ont joué qu'une seule saison chez
les pros mais ils ont du culot exemple
crible et jordan enfin hardaway et
reggie miller dans le rôle du passeur
feront aussi partie de l'équipe
aucune autre équipe ne pourra jamais
égaler la dream team
1 les plus grands talents ils étaient
réunis michael jordan magic johnson
larry bird
on ne pourra jamais être comparé on
essaiera juste faire comme d'être
champion olympique il restera encore
deux places à pourvoir et tout le monde
espère que magic johnson sera appelé à
rejoindre cette dream team 3 puisque
c'est son souhait
en revanche bye bye de charles barkley
bye bye michael jordan ces deux figures
du basket pro américains ont décliné la
sélection mais avec eux c'est une part
du rail qui disparaît voit la fin de
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo d'isabel martinez
qui nous annoncent bien sûr du temps
chaud pour demain à 20h50 les gens de
mogador à ces horreurs 15 environ le
dernier journal de florence dauchez
demain dans les 4 vérités rémy roche
recevra le professeur jean pierre olié
médecin psychiatre à 13h bien sûr vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian quant à moi
je retrouverai à 20h et d'ici là bonne
soirée sur france 2